here's a puzzle for you the UK's capital
city is one of the world's most
important Financial hubs and yet many
britons find their own money matters are
blighted by poor maths I can't tell you
the amount of times I get the uh well I
couldn't do maths at school what's gone
wrong with maths in our education system
sometimes a bad experience in secondary
school or sometimes just to fear you
know off Max we are teaching mathematics
at the moment as though everything
outside the classroom walls is the same
as it ever was who is this affecting if
you don't get level four in maths and
English you're written off
and what can be done about it
the UK population has shockingly bad
number skills compared to other
countries
and there are two sides to this equation
a significant proportion of kids leave
school each year without a good math
qualification and more than half of
working age adults are estimated to have
low basic numeracy
five is going to be B Goods huge efforts
have gone into improving State schools
in England since the 1990s with massive
progress in primary schools but an oecd
report showed that in 2011 young people
in the UK had even worse numeracy than
older Generations math skills are patchy
and unequal and with an exam system that
creates hidden losers
a third of our 15 and 16 year olds are
destined to miss out on a pass grade at
GCSE maths locking them out of later
opportunities at college and at work
so I won't sit back and allow this
cultural sense that it's okay to be bad
at maths to put our children at a
disadvantage and the Prime Minister
wants everyone to learn some maths up to
the new school leaving age of 18.
so put simply without a solid foundation
in maths our children risk being left
behind so it turns out that there's
actually already a debate raging about
whether the way that maths is taught and
examined in schools is actually
hindering gaining competent number
skills this really concerns me I've
written about education policy for a
number of years I now have my own kids
in the state school system I really want
to get out and find out what creative
ideas are bubbling away as to how we can
tackle the nation's lack of number
skills
hello everyone welcome to the community
garden here at Stockwell Center of
Morley College let's start off bear with
us at a gardening class on a sunny
weekday morning at Morley College in
South London and in particular this is
our one foot garden so you can see every
square has been divided up and we're
going to be thinking about how we can
really get the most out of the garden so
it's a really exciting way of of of
putting Mass into practice we're talking
about spacing out onion seedlings but
it's a course funded by the government
to tackle the adult part of the numeracy
crisis in this case we could call it
maths by stealth if each of these
is a ruler apart and then you have a
right angle
you know that that's a straight line
then you can map out your garden
those who didn't Master maths or even
basic numeracy skills at school come to
community colleges like this to try
again and see if they can get over the
vital hurdle of a mass qualification
but first these cunning lecturers like
Gerald Jones and Shola shabawale are
tempting them in and hoping to build up
an appetite to get back into formal
learning so you find a way of sort of
hiding the maths effectively people say
I hate math so so the government
multiply program this is a national
multi-million pound program is designed
to try to help people overcome that fear
and we've taken that to mean teaching
math so it doesn't feel like you're back
in school it doesn't trigger those big
strong emotions that people have around
around maths so you can in fact embed
some maths in almost anything yeah yeah
we've got um Spanish with maths if
you're learning art or jewelry or
Ceramics every course that we could
think of because it's very hard to live
your life and from morning to dusk
without using mass time Money travel
it's everything is maths you presumably
would want to tempt people to actually
getting a mass qualification of some
sort definitely the maths that can be
weaved in can be can go from really very
basic where you're just counting and
looking at squares and measuring and you
could go up to really complex like doing
trigonometry when you look at the big
vegetable patch you can actually look at
Angles you can look at hypotenuse those
Concepts that you would think are
abstract you can actually help students
to see how all those things relate to
one another which AIDS understanding
the gardening group offered a taste of
how lack of functional masks can be
imaginatively remedied for those adults
stuck with a numeracy deficit but our
second stop is a school where the pupils
mostly sail through there's no hiding
the math lessons here at shoreditch Park
Academy interior angle where the GCSE
pass rate was 80 this year 10 questions
way above the average for England and
Wales
this is an angle this is an angle it's a
much more traditional setup for learning
trigonometry and with no lettuces in
sight two sides and two angles cyan rule
three sides of one angle cosine rule
[Music]
that was insane it was like being 15
again
clearly for some people it's conceptual
and there's a real dopamine hit from
getting the right answer
but for everyone else you know that that
world of equations is a sort of rite of
passage When You're 15 16. you never
come back to it again the GCSE
trigonometry class was taken by head of
math Sam Mitchell who we managed to
catch as he dashed in and out of class
so in the past when I've interviewed
educationalists about the UK and our
maths problem yeah they've said the
really verbal culture
parents play word games with their kids
you go to Asia everybody's playing
numbers games I can't tell you the
amount of times I get the uh well I
couldn't do maths at school or uh maths
was never for me when I'm in front of a
parent and that's a really kind of
painful phrase to hear they think that
now with jobs require Excel or or a
calculator all those things therefore
they don't think that numeracy is
important beneath that but obviously it
is with over 50
pupils on free School meals which means
they're in the most low income
households the staff here know they are
giving these kids a leg up a passport on
to better things even though the maths
exams have become tougher in recent
years
Sam do you think that math at school has
become too abstract but I definitely
think for your typical students the
abstract Concepts that they're learning
about is are quite difficult to put into
kind of real life context for us to get
the engagement that we would want from
students whether that's you know talking
about your classic trigonometry as you
saw me Teach earlier or whether that is
even kind of a graph itself we don't see
enough of those in context when we look
at the idea of risk and rewards right it
doesn't always work I'm sure that we've
all seen that in the news Bitcoin nfts
to get that real world relevance Sam was
also giving his GCSE group a financial
literacy lesson it's a pilot scheme with
materials designed by the charity flick
and being used in pshe classes that's
personal social health and economic
education
it's a national curriculum requirement
though not tested and often neglected
and full disclosure this project is
backed by the Ft I found the class
pretty switched on interested in the
ideas of risk and return and even in
crypto pandemic and look what that did
to the stock market it was a very
vocal group I thought are they that
vocal in their maths classes I wonder
depends on the time of day sometimes
um no probably not it's that real life
context isn't it yeah uh that is
particularly for students in year 11 now
and the verge of going out into the real
world they have this idea that financial
literacy is a really important part of
being independent and they all quite
want to make money
so teachers are under pressure to cram
in this real world math alongside the
more traditional topics in the GCSE
maths exam and with overloaded
timetables
this school is unusual in getting so
many to respond to both
since the pandemic the UK's achievement
Gap in maths between deprived kids and
their well-off peers has become even
wider a decades progress in narrowing it
has been lost according to the education
policy Institute
if we're not careful that's going to
make the national problem of lack of
numeracy
even tougher to tackle in the years to
come maybe one of the ways of doing that
as they've suggested here is to change
this GCSE curriculum which is very
academic and is essentially
you know a straight line from Pythagoras
through me sitting my o levels decades
ago to these kids here sitting gcses
[Music]
the way our exam system structured means
around a third of every year group
sitting the math GCSE is destined to
fail
since 2015 if they don't get that vital
grade 4 as a pass is now known they have
worse options for advanced courses both
academic and Vocational enrolled at Fe
colleges they have to reset the maths
exam again and again and again head
teachers organizations unhappy about all
this demoralization have called these
kids the Forgotten third they want a
different set of basic maths and English
qualifications that would give many more
a passport into more learning or a good
job at Morley meanwhile they are busy
picking up the pieces we have students
who have failed at math in secondary
school or because of sometimes you know
bad experience and also because
yes the fear you know of mats and
sometimes Concepts seem to be broken
down into little steps just to you know
to overcome you know those barriers
this may seem strange but those barriers
are now blocking so many young people
that even the man who introduced the
GCSE exams
Circle the solid that has seven vertices
looks at those endless resets and wants
a radical overhaul
it's the game what are you learning here
as education secretary in the late 1980s
it was conservative politician Kenneth
Baker who designed the current system
the reforms which I'll be introducing
over the next 12 months will improve the
quality of education for all our
children throughout the country
she finds a letter at the time most 15
or 16 year olds took o levels with the
less able pupils entered for cses but
the all ability GCSE maths Lord Baker
introduced should now he argues be
retired
when I arrived he was deep in a
quadratic equation as someone with the
mind of a Puzzler he finds it diverting
but not necessarily useful I have to say
having left school when I was 18. I have
never used a quadratic equation in my
life
nor have I used trigonometry what do you
think about this idea that the UK has as
we see you know put it an anti-maths
mindset reading is the important quality
that must come first before everything
and that has dominated the whole of the
Department of Education since 1870 and
the curriculum that we're now following
in schools in GCSE was announced in 1904
one English one maths three Sciences
foreign language and history of
geography and the numeracy does not
materialize so importantly in that quite
frankly now that the age for leaving
educational training has been raised to
18 Baker is worried that pushing
everyone through the same old academic
hoops at GCSE condemns too many to
downgrade their Ambitions there's been a
very strong emphasis in recent
secretaries of State on this idea of
reintroducing rigor
and making the math GCSE
very much more academic GCSE there
should be much more functional maths
from 11 to 16. you don't have to worry
about the master mathematicians they're
some of the brightest kids in the
country you have to worry about the kids
below them
why not shake up the exams he says maybe
with two subjects academic and core or
functional maths a bit like English
language and literature which separate
the real life and basic skills from the
other knowledge
in the GCSE exams each other if you
don't get level 4 in maths and English
you're written off
so something has gone wrong at a very
early stage people have been turned to
be turned against figure words and maths
it is a bit too complicated for them he
wants core maths taught in all schools
cool maths must deal with basic
calculations addition multiplication and
division fractions and decimals and
percentages and margins because it
doesn't matter whether you you sell
bonds or whether you sell British planes
you've got to understand the difference
between the gross profit percentage and
the net profit otherwise you won't be in
business
Lord Baker who's really the main
architect of
the assess
system that we've inherited in English
schools and to hear the extent of his
doubts as to whether gcses are really
fit for purpose whether Mass GCSE or
indeed Mass a level
can help tackle the numeracy crisis in
the UK
that's quite a wake-up call
so how much damage does poor numeracy do
to people once they are out in the adult
world of jobs and household budgets
I caught up with Sasha romanovic at the
House of Commons as she petitioned those
with the power to change the system
heads up fair for all finance a UK
charity helping the financially
vulnerable and excluded
a former accountant she once ran Grant
Thornton and studied maths all the way
to 18 as Rishi sunak wants everyone to
do in some form
still every now and then do you solving
a quadratic equation to work something
out but actually I think this is where
it comes to the sort of numeracy versus
maths you know the comfort of being able
to scan a list of numbers and without
actually adding them up knowing broadly
yeah that adds up that makes sense
she agrees numeracy and financial
education are important but says it's of
limited help lecturing people already
failed by the system that maths however
it's taught might save them there are
about 17 and a half million people in
the UK who are in financially vulnerable
circumstances when you look at the root
causes behind that numeracy is only one
part of the problem if someone's in a
deficit income situation you know
learning to budget better isn't going to
Magikarp that they're going to be able
to have more money so Financial
capability and numeracy absolutely
important but one of a multitude of
causes of low Financial resilience we
know that a lot of kids already Fall by
the wayside with maths as it's taught in
schools is this the right approach so
some people say they're frightened of
numbers and scared of maths but I think
that you know if we can approach it from
how do we make numbers meaningful to
people and if you maybe present things
in a pie chart anyone can make sense of
that because most people have argued at
some point with someone around whether
they're getting the fair share of the
pie
once you have that money into our
account
what are we gonna do with it what does
someone who knows classroom maths Inside
Out make of this debate
Rebecca Rhoden tutors GCSE maths
candidates and taught the subject at an
all ability Secondary School
she now also works for the ft-backed
charity flick improving financial
literacy for all age groups there's a
lot to navigate even with a pay slip
isn't that and I think you'll find lots
of young people get the shock of their
lives when the piece that comes through
with the rise of gig work she sees exam
candidates scared of numbers and coming
out of school unable to deal with
today's complicated world of navigating
irregular income budgeting for hard
times or handling a pension outside of
regular employment so if somebody gets
that pass in Mass GCSE which is so
important for later life is that a
guarantee that they can cope with
numbers in everyday life I'm not sure
it's always the case I think we could
have somebody that passes with knowing
their indices like five to the power of
three but not being able to apply a
percentage change to a release for
question or being able to sufficiently
analyze a core bit of data Rebecca
worries that maths at GCSE isn't quite
working whether you're in the group
taking the so-called higher papers or
instead the foundation papers for the
less able where you can only ever hope
for a pass
I don't think we're necessarily meeting
the needs of either of those groups so
the foundation a stretch to how to apply
lots and lots of different content which
could be extremely overwhelming
especially if they don't have their
basic number skills and then for the
higher set I'm a fan actually of the
inclusion of more problem-solving
questions but we're still finding
students struggling through and then
also not being fully equipped with
functional math
and if you can't get over the hurdle it
prolongs the agony
think it's deeply damaging what we're
doing to some of those students
potentially failing on those papers and
then having to reset and reset and reset
that's a disaster really because some of
the biggest decisions we make are around
numbers whether it's taking out a loan
or putting your money into a savings
account so there's something's broken
the system that needs to be addressed
talking to Rebecca makes me think that
if if
feel they're not able to prepare young
people
maybe the Prime Minister should actually
look at the current compulsory maths
curriculum rather than asking for more
maths further on
I wanted to see what somebody who
Delights in maths can bring to the
discussion Alf Coles a professor at
Bristol University is an expert on how
maths is taught and recently co-authored
I can't do maths why children say it and
how to make a difference
which definitely sees the beauty of
maths not just a set of useful skills
and worries about shutting people out
worsening the UK's educational divide
you might describe his views as a
Counterpoint to the campaign to strip
out or Hive off those abstract elements
if you get into doing mathematics then
you you read like a script and if you
imagine it like a music script you read
it and you can hear the music
but the way it's often taught and
presented as though all the game is is
just trying to analyze this bit of
writing there's no sense that there's
something else it's pointing to
so the way you talk about maths is a
source of Joy yes but do you understand
why so many people talk about learning
math something that sort of scarred them
slightly no I do I mean it's been talked
about as cognitive bullying what happens
in some mathematics classrooms where
children are forced to revisit sites of
failure and learn sort of fractions
again and again and again and so we end
up teaching people the same content for
maybe five years at secondary school and
then if they haven't succeeded then
teach them again in these classes so I
don't think it's any surprise that
people are then completely turned off
Alf explains that schools look at the
exam requirements and then work back
from them fitting their classroom
teaching to how their pupils and the
school will be measured so I spent 15
years teaching in secondary schools and
I think teachers I think there's there's
incredible asset in this country and
teachers are incredibly pragmatic but I
think there are these sort of ideas that
cross Society really uh that influencing
the curriculum and influence of our
assessments and then to things being
taught
in a way that doesn't connect with
people there's a lot of people who would
like to see a separate numeracy
qualification what do you think of that
idea well yeah I mean I would be worried
that it would divide along class and
socioeconomic lines and I think if you
look at other countries China for
example almost everybody in China
achieves a very high level in
mathematics so I just don't think it's
the case that there's a proportion of
the population who will just never get
math and shouldn't be taughted to me it
seems like it's one of one of children's
rights to to be offered some of these
cultural achievements in mathematics in
the UK which is plagued with lifelong
disadvantage for the education Have Nots
he has a warning there could be
unintended consequences of introducing
two different Pathways for Maths for me
the danger is that we we give up on
students early in their school career
we've got
um evidence of children who you know
have not attained very highly in maths
being able to be successful on
Pythagoras and trigonometry and things
that are way ahead of what would have
been expected of them curriculum and I
would be really sad if what went along
with a sort of more functional
qualification was the closing down of
possibilities some critics say the UK's
problem is a lack of basic skills in
maths but Alf and other experts say
schools should teach better stats
literacy that's an essential skill in
today's world if you look at the skills
that we need it's things like how do you
look at a graph of covid infections and
make sense of what's likely to happen so
if we're thinking about the kind of
skills you need to function as an adult
I would see it much more as around data
literacy and statistical literacy
political debate is full now of
Statistics being bombarded at people so
how are you able to to make sense of
those in a kind of critical way
it's been really good to come here to
Bristol and talk to ALF because really
he's buzzing with enthusiasm for the
idea that abstract math academic math
actually gives young people an enormous
amount of
cultural capital as well as intellectual
stimulation that should be for everyone
numbers are everywhere and there's
something all of us use every day
without even thinking about it so making
this film we have really uncovered what
I would call a degree of panic about the
challenge of improving the nation's
numeracy we simply cannot allow poor
numeracy to cost our economy tens of
billions a year but there is an emerging
consensus and that's about overhauling
the way that maths and numbers are
taught and examined it feels that mass
is so important that we can't let people
drift away from it but the problem is
there is a real divide
over whether you should Hive off as a
separate set of qualifications
functional numeracy
and also how do we fit in financial
literacy and all these life skills to do
with numbers that seem to be lacking in
the current examination system core
maths which strips out the more academic
and Abstract content is already a
growing option at a level it has
elements of finance and of the sort of
statistical skills that both Alf and
Sasha would like to see but for 16 year
olds outside Scotland and Wales that is
numeracy at GCSE equivalent level is not
widely available
perhaps there does need to be a
conversation between people setting the
syllabus the specification the
examination bodies and people who are
very very distant from understanding
maths we are teaching mathematics at the
moment as though everything outside the
classroom walls is the same as it ever
was floods fires you name it Mass
migration and Mathematics is hugely
implicated in these things in in
modeling in predicting and communicating
climate change and all sorts of things
we are crying out for a new question we
really have the education reform needn't
take a long time parents want it
students want it teachers wanted
so why isn't it being done
it's a huge challenge to bridge that
numeracy Gap with people struggling with
a cost of living crisis and a government
wary of spending on extra teachers or
resources shoreditch head of maths Sam
Mitchell maybe the GCSE becomes more
core maths or we have extra time in our
curriculum that would be great but I
can't tell you how long we will have
maths adverts out for jobs at this
school so the idea of being able to
recruit double the amount of Math
teachers or have people who can teach
those skills and are trained to teach
those things is pretty far-fetched
looking at teaching recruitment at the
moment when it comes to sunax promise of
a more mass Savvy Nation it's going to
take more teachers and inventive
thinking we need both rigor and real
world relevance
navigating numbers will always be more
of a necessity than a vocation for many
of us especially when numbers on a bill
start to get as scary as a math exam
but the problems are particularly acute
for those whose struggles are hidden
outside the mainstream a lot of
financial education is designed by
numerous people and it works really
great for numerous people but it doesn't
work for people who aren't naturally
numerate and when somebody is in crisis
their ability to think and process stuff
is about that thing and so saying to
them at that point all right we'll learn
some maths is not helpful so in a
frequency table we need a population
where far more of us are equipped to
cope with everyday calculations
but without shutting out already
disadvantaged kids from The Riches of
the math so beautiful that it sounds
like music to enthusiasts like Alf Coles
it's a policy puzzle we're yet to find a
solution
in the meantime at least I can get an
answer to my question about soccer TOA
well Sam can you just remind me that
terrifying word that I heard again after
so many decades soccer Tower what what
does it stand for again because it did
strike a chill into my heart did it I
mean not all Math teachers like teaching
it like this uh but it's a sign of the
angle equals opposite over the
hypotenuse cause of the angle equals the
adjacent over the hopelessness and tan
of the angle equals the opposite over
the adjacent it's the right angle how
could I forgotten that no I know exactly
I'll just I'll just stick to the soccer
Tower there's a few Giggles the first
time you teach it but uh yeah we've got
there in the end